Hey guys, it's Jan here.
I know we're all really excited to see Ryan
Reynolds play the iconic Deadpool in his own
movie, so I wanted to take a look at 10 things
you probably didn't know about the film.
And just before I kick off, I've got an awesome
giveaway, so if you'd like a chance to win
some cool Deadpool merch, make sure you subscribe
and comment about the movie on this video.
For more details and ways to enter the comp,
check out the Gleam link in the video description
below!
Right, now for those Deadpool movie facts...
To produce Deadpool's scarred look, make-up
department head Bill Corso created thin, semi-transparent
silicone prosthetics that showed muscles,
blood and tissue under the skin.
It took around four hours to get Ryan Reynolds
ready and he wore ten of those super-thin
silicone prosthetics on his head and, for
one scene, even had them applied all over
his body.
According to Reynolds, the prosthetics felt
like wearing a wet diaper on his face!
The character of Colossus, who's super-strong
and super-tall, is mostly computer-generated
with the aid of a motion capture performance.
And the fact his steel-like armoured form
is completely reflective was quite a challenge
for the filmmakers.
To solve the problem, they used a 3-D camera
system to capture all the action that takes
place around Colossus.
Then they placed that action onto Colossus's
body as a reflection.
So, for example, when Deadpool runs around
Colossus, we can see the reflection of Deadpool
on his mutant ally's metal body.
Speaking of Colossus, actor Daniel Cudmore
who played the character in X-Men 2, The Last
Stand, and Days Of Future Past, was offered
the part for Deadpool, but turned it down
as not only is the character computer-generated
but also the filmmakers wanted to use another
actor's voice for the part.
In the end, Colossus is played by three actors
in Deadpool.
Andre Tricoteux did the motion capture performance,
Greg LaSalle did the facial motion capture,
and Stefan Kapicic provided the voice of Colossus.
When it came to Deadpool's fight scenes, the
filmmakers wanted to combine bad-ass stunts
with playful wise-cracking.
So, Ryan Reynolds took cues from none other
than heavyweight boxing great Muhammad Ali,
not only in terms of Ali's moves in the ring
but also with regards to Ali's technique of
trash-talking his opponents both before and
during a match.
In fact, actor Ed Skrein has said that the
clashes between his character Ajax and Deadpool
in the movie are reminiscent of Muhammad Ali
versus Joe Frazier.
Stunt coordinator Philip Silvera and his team
have created a hybrid style for scenes where
Deadpool fights with his signature katanas.
The style mixes 'tactical thinking, Japanese
and Chinese sword work', and the kind of strikes
used in Filipino martial arts.
And speaking of Deadpool's katanas, Ryan Reynolds
has said on Twitter that he's named them Bea
and Arthur, presumably because in the comic
books the Merc with a Mouth just happens to
be a huge fan of actress Bea Arthur who starred
in TV comedy The Golden Girls.
Ryan Reynolds spent six months in the gym
getting beefed up to play Deadpool, and actually
threw his back out on the first day of training!
But by the time he came to wear his costume,
his muscles were so big that they had to remove
the muscle layer in the suit.
Many superhero suits have a polyurethane-type
muscle suit underneath to add definition on
camera, but according to director Tim Miller
and Ryan Reynolds when Reynolds put on the
suit with the muscle layer it looked over
the top, so they removed it to give Reynolds
more of the classic Deadpool look.
When Reynolds finished filming Deadpool, memories
of the shoot weren't the only thing he took
with him.
In fact, the actor swiped one of his Deadpool
costumes, which he reckons he more than earned
after waiting 10 years to finally make the
movie.
Deadpool may be R-rated, but apparently there
was still some stuff that was deemed just
too offensive to make it into the final cut.
One particular bar scene featuring Ryan Reynolds
and TJ Miller as Deadpool and his pal Weasel
was cut down because, according to director
Tim Miller, it went 'too far' and was particularly
mean and offensive to so many people.
But even the final cut of the movie proved
too much for China, where the movie's been
refused permission to screen in cinemas due
to its violence, nudity and graphic language.
The character of Negasonic Teenage Warhead,
who's played by Brianna Hildebrand, was created
by comic book writer Grant Morrison and named
after the song Negasonic Teenage Warhead by
the band Monster Magnet.
Warhead first appeared in 2001 in the New
X-Men comic books.
Deadpool screenwriters Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick said they were given a pre-approved
list of characters they could use for the
movie and as soon as they saw the name Negasonic
Teenage Warhead they just had to use it!
Former mixed martial artist Gina Carano certainly
isn't afraid of doing many of her own stunts
in movies like Haywire and Deadpool, but there's
one thing she does absolutely detest and that's
spiders.
While filming a fight scene between Colossus
and Carano's character Angel Dust, the MMA-star-turned-actress
spent a considerable amount of time getting
thrown around in the dirt at a junkyard, getting
the 'messiest' she's ever been in a brawl.
But the main thing on her mind throughout
was whether the crew had done a spider check
before filming!
Now, what are you most excited about for the
Deadpool movie?
And what would you like to see in a sequel?
Let me know in the comments below!
I've got more Deadpool videos on the way including
a movie review and an easter egg video, and
I'll add annotations here when they're live.
And don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment about the movie on this video for
a chance to win some awesome Deadpool merch!
For more details and ways to enter the comp,
check out the Gleam link in the video description
below!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!